we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a very good
question about what happens if Trump is
the nominee and loses in 24. take a
listen to this it's something I've been
thinking about for sure
hey David
should we be worried about what Trump
supporters are going to do if Trump
loses in 2024
I believe we should be worried the
question really that's being asked
is
will Maga Riot again
if Trump loses in 2024. I hope the
answer is no
I pray the answer is no I don't even
pray but this I might pray for I I
really hope that they are not going to
Riot if he loses
um I do think it makes sense for law
enforcement to be more prepared Maybe
but uh honestly everything surrounding
Trump lately has been so low energy I
mean bear you know with the arrest there
were going to be big protests there was
a protest with like 40 people and a
couple hundred members of the media and
police not a big showing let's hope that
Maga remains as deflated as they've been
and that no matter what outcome there is
there's no violence we're thinking very
far ahead and we're going to wait and
see on the bonus show today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money yeah
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad number one we'll be
making money on the bonus show number
two the Supreme Court is preserving
access to the abortion pill for now and
for now is a big thing uh we will talk
about the continued expansion of AI
including songs written and performed by
AI are you an AI NPC listening to AI
music and you don't even know it what
would that do to you okay we'll talk
about that and we will also talk about
new polling this this is kind of just
depressing
majorities don't want Biden nor Trump to
run in 2024 based on new polling what
does it mean all of those stories and
more on the bonus show which you can
sign up for at joinpakman.com I'll see
everybody then or right back here
tomorrow